[Music]
Ah, tan
Ah
, I want to challenge the bucket pudding
a
. I made a huge pudding before, but I made it with a big ball, but
I pulled it in by gravity and made a big pudding.  Then I used the package because it was a bucket pudding. The
numbers are
like the text pudding.
It's a plier that I had to remove first.
[Music]
tan
Oops
me
[Music]
I
can't use it because it's dangerous water-cooled after the hot water
.
I'm connected to another, but
1 a 2
[Music]
[Music] I
'll use another one
. This isn't enough.
[Music]
I want Hun to take this here and keep it here. I
can go.
I have
another yuan for the nurse, so
please keep it.
[Music]
Ah,
I have to be a coster
[Music]  ]
Kapa Kim's view, I'm
swaying, I took a breath and shook,
this looks delicious. I
'm working on it with Oi station
.
What's the setting of one step
today It's
pretty tight
user
I'm
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah  I
wonder if I
'll make it again I'm lacking in beauty I'll eat pudding Burley Super Power [Music] Just this eh [Music] Come on [Music] I'm wondering if I should do my best
Because of that, it looks like it's chatty
[Music]
Who
[Music] I
told you, I said, I
fell behind
[Music] It
felt like it was going to fall a little, but it collapsed.
Bai
Ah, that's the one I
did
[Music]
Honestly on the 4th day, is
n't it me I'm hungry?
2 Dub Ah Ah
That's right, it's okay if you go, yeah
Poin
[music]